بعد عام على الاجتياح الشامل للاراضي
الاوكرانيه من قبل الجيش الروسي الذي توقف
عند اسوار العاصمه كيف مضطر معظم سكانها
على المغادره على عجل والنزوح غربا بل
واللجوء الى دول الجوار فاصبحت كيين خليه
موحشه تكادلات ترى فيها الا الحواجز
الامنيه للجيش في شوارع شبه خاليه اليكسي
بولين احد سكان العاصمه الذين كانوا شهودا
على بدايه الحرب يتحدث عن اول يوم والفتره
الاولى للحرب
في اليوم الاول خاصه انني اعيش في منطقه
قريبه من مدخل
الانفجارات كانت السيارات هناك باعداد
هائله الناس كانوا يحاولون باسرع ما
يمكنهم مغادره المدينه في الايام الاولى
والمحل التجاريه كانت مغلقه بسبب الغارات
الجويه الناس كانوا يقفون في الصفوف من
اجل الخبز والمواد التموينيه
ها هي العاصمه بعد عام على الحرب تعود الى
الحياه ويعود اليها مواطنها الذين يحاولون
التعايش مع اوضاع فرضتها الحرب كالقصف
المستمر والظلام الدامس في الليل
وانقطاعات الكهرباء لساعات طويله وصعوبه
التنقل وفقدان الناس لوظائفهم بسبب اغلاق
كثير من الاعمال التجاريه
كانت مدينه كييف حيه ممتلئه بالناس وجميله
وبسبب الحرب اصبحت المدينه خاليه في
الايام الاولى كنا هنا قضينا اسبوعا كاملا
في الملجا
خلال فتره الحرب كييف تغيرت بشكل دائم في
البدايه كانت المدينه خاليه والان عدا
الناس وكثير من المتاجر فتحت ابوابها
الناس قليلون في المدينه وفي كييف بقيت
محل البقاله تعمل في ايام الحرب الوضع كان
صعبا جدا والان افضل بكثير هذا المشهد
يتكرر بين الفينه والاخرى فالروس يواصلون
قصف العاصمه الا ان الناس قد اعتادوا ذلك
ويواصلون حياتهم رغما عن المخاطر الكبيره
واراهصات اجتياح جديد في الذكرى السنويه
للحرب الا ان الجيش يقول انه عزز دفاعاته
الهندسيه والعسكريه وخاصه دفاعات العاصمه
كييف وانه لن يتكرر ذلك المشهد الذي حدث
في بدايه الحرب حين حاصر الروس العاصمه
حذيفه عادل العربيه كيف